I lost that funny bird yesterday,
if I remember correctly,
this exchange variant again,
okay, yes, I had that before
against another
player flaps
not bad but not as if
you can do so much
so
you can somehow use the queen
position
first could only do for F5 uh
bishop G4 do
directly the 4D knight the four knights
the four bishops the four
is of course in the  Rook line full
in but good I always run three but
it looks very consistent okay come on so
black tries
to open the center right now the king has
n't got high here from white
think now ed knight D4
knight D4 bishop D4 comes on okay
well logical of course I ca
n't take it on Z3 yet that makes a
strange impression in my
opinion
you can somehow use it now that at the
moment the knight is hanging
then five idea
knight B4 is maybe another
idea but I just thought queen B1
doesn't look like that  so it looks like if you
can use it directly
normal move would also be
queen B6
yes I have to move at some point yes
four I want to
play bishop beef here now or queen A5
there can maybe win on the many
pawns but
only has to move with concessions
so
C5 is hanging through the knight at the moment,
I still have four
such
simple access runners E7
with the idea that the knight does
n't stand well on A4 either,
aha, I actually thought I
had knights like 4
and that's uncomfortable here I thought
so C7 well I can take A4 yes okay
if I hit A4 back then 4 so
rooks 8
a lot a lot of tempies so okay
we do
so he might have the B3 in between
but then I can hit A2 like this
and here I was actually thinking B6
and  then tower simply E2
to then have bishop A6
Minis at least maybe we'll go
other things
I haven't seen
well it may not be bad but
I still haven't seen him
so that C2 maybe so that they two
morning
dead runner A6
hope do D2 I have  at least the
chess
on C1
if he plays C4 with it I can
do E2 badly Tommy 2 we have
two bishops A6
I only have one minute left
but give me two is just such a
direct threat as well as bishop A6
bishop A6 comes e.g  on knight E5
yes he probably had to do that
I have more than a move repetition here
could also give B1 the shaft
probably similar
now I could also beat B2 must
that one difference
is of course very very gamble with with
no time on the clock
probably it would be  more sensible
to do the Remy simply because of the time
yes it would probably
have been more sensible to do the Remy
Shame
but apparently hadn't
counted on it
anyway two checkmates
or someone here
yes that was a bit happy now
but of course it was also a
dangerous attack yes
probably maybe training
the computer here watching what finds it
oh my god F4 just hangs oh help help
I can just hit F4 I dork
whereby
the position is also totally
won interesting okay
plus one is over
now they do one and now we do
two  it's really good for
black again, funny,
it's really matt, yes, I was lucky
with 10 seconds left on the clock,
but before that I think I
played really, really well